in order to learn how to repair this
engine these apprentices have to take it
apart over and over in a year and a half
the young Egyptians will have completed
their apprenticeship is automobile
maintenance technicians only a third of
the applicants were accepted for the
limited number of places in the program
Achmed fuad is glad he got in all I want
to learn more about cars and about
mechatronics it's a new technology in
Egypt and I want to learn about
automotive technology English lessons
and a course and good manners are part
of the training high end cars are
especially popular in Egypt and the
mechanics who provide after-sales
servicing need to be presentable the
mercedes apprenticeship is a special
project which other businesses want to
use as a model qualified employees are
not just in short supply at mercedes
other car makers also urgently need
trained technicians but the
apprenticeship program is still in its
infancy just got a piece of caca a
noodle there have been too few training
opportunities up to now school leavers
here get their training learning by
doing one university graduates and more
like engineers they're overqualified for
working in garages didn't the situation
in Egypt in the wake of Mohamed morsi's
ouster is still chaotic the country's
economy in tatters officially only
thirteen percent of Egyptian youth are
unemployed unofficially the figure is
more like thirty percent those who can't
find a job can turn to Egypt's youth
ministry it has just launched a new
program to tackle youth unemployment we
are trying to organize a number of job
fairs in cooperation was private sector
and governmental sector to allow the use
who are not having the opportunity to
work to have different opportunities to
participate to apply in to have a job
but
may be true with you this can't work
unless there is a step from the use of
themselves these apprentices have taken
that step they're all motivated and will
be finished with their apprenticeship
with Mercedes in a few months if the
project is successful than other
companies will follow suit these
particular young people have just gotten
a big head start in kairos very
competitive job market